gang real quick before we get this
episode started summer is going into
full swing and so is the ru
garbage keep it moving 20 21
tour oh yeah we're going to be coming to
a town near you
for a little bit of stand up and we're
going to be answering your
garbage questions kippy tell them what
they need to know yeah guys on uh
june 22nd we'll be in chicago still a
few tickets left for that
uh june 23rd we'll be in indy helium
get tickets for that and then buddy
we're all over the place july
14th columbus funny bone july 15th
cleveland hilarities
august 11th rhode island comedy
connection august 12th
left boston those tickets are cooking
that's going to sell out
get those tickets then august 25th we're
at new brunswick stress factory and then
august 26th we're at mcgooby's joke
house in timonium
maryland right outside of baltimore i
like it gang get some ticks
come out and see it's going to be a
fantastic fun time a mix of stand-up
comedy in the ayg game
come out and hang with uncle hank and
your aunt kippy
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your
favorite comedians are classy
individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast what's
that
this is r u garbage oh baby it's a
little show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and we find out they
grow up to be classy
or just a big old piece of trash
i'm your host holy coming at you on a
beautiful day i'm down here in antoine's
basement i got a cool new dion oh my god
so look out kids if you see me at the
skate park
or hanging out at the boards this summer
come hang i'm cool
i'm not five i'm not 5-0 is that what
you think the kids at the skate park are
wearing
all right okay just making sure what
reality we're living in
my co-host is coming at you from a
generation who doesn't get us
he's the ceo you're talking to other 45
year olds what are you talking about
no one under 32 listens to this he's the
ceo of are you garbage
all right he's an inter-bat an
international businessman tactically
he's dead bozo around here so i gotta
show him a little respect
give it up for cue ball kevin james ryan
everybody
i don't know why i already got paid this
month screw you
i loser i was gonna get a straight intro
given your attitude all day today i
should have known something was up
catch you at the end of the month what
time do you have to get back to football
practice
you're dressed like a [__] like a
linebacker
you look like you just found out about
tick-tock
oh man dude that is a tough look holy
[__]
shout out to burlington you look like an
undercover grimace right now
hanging out where the burgers at huh
boys hanging out at the wendy's
i know another place you guys want to go
uh stay here
hey what's up gang happy to be here
thanks for tuning in as always please
make sure you rate view subscribe on
itunes do it full video available on
youtube and as you know those numbers
are
true true to [__] roof patreon.com
is putting all the other dude things to
shame patreon patreon.com so i'll show
you garbage
is [__] cooking guys if you're not
familiar uh you can get bonus episodes
at ayg
uh you get episodes of hard feelings
which is a little bit behind the
curtains uh you know the show behind the
show per se
that's right uh and then also we do a
live stream every month with our top
tier patrons which is a good [__]
time so
check it out and then also we got some
[__] live shows coming up
uh this is dropping this week a couple
of tickies left in ac maybe they added a
couple of more
that was sold out we got you we don't
know what's going on but make sure you
get tickets
we got chicago there's about 10 left
there maybe
uh in that second show and then we got
[__] cleveland coming up we got
columbus coming up we got
rhode island indy coming up next week
could you give up on indy's skipped over
no i forgot about it we got a lot of
[__] dates is what i'm trying to say
come out there and see a show there boys
flatlining in india huh nah we're doing
it right
we're doing okay never make it out not
one of our biggest markets i'll say that
for a state that has legal fireworks and
five dollar cigarettes
i think they had the keys of the city
when we got there
it's got a cinder block on it listen
gang that's neither here nor there how
about a nice shout out
to our producer extraordinaire word on
the street is he could drive a golf ball
a lot longer than
kevin toby mcmuffin t-bone
mcmullen what's up dudes hey hey buddy
how are you i'm [__]
chilling dude i had my little chef's hat
and my oven mitts on
[__] cooking this weekend yeah dude
toby was putting any [__] hours he
was
he was sending me [__] i'm like jesus
christ i'm trying to vacation with a
couple of white calls down here
i'm down in a while i'm trying to
[__] let my hairs my balls hang out
based on a lot of talk about this kid in
the out in the league man people saying
this kid can slice him and dice i know
that limo video on hot clips
guys so if you're not familiar we
dropped foley's first limo ride which
might be
toby's best piece of business so far
we're just getting started it's a
[__] that there's a full 10 minutes
on
uh on the patreon there that you know a
lot of people join to see that kid's a
man on fire look out
yeah the one thing i did want to discuss
and i hope you're okay with this
because i've been laughing about it the
entire [__] weekend oh boy
since you said it to us i can't remember
where we were
when you said have you ever called you
ever accidentally called your teacher
mommy ha ha oh that was a they were
actually called your teacher mom
yeah brutal dude dude
what kind of inbred backwards trash do
you have to be
to let that slip out at any age it's
probably like
it's just like uh uh yeah i don't know
that's [__] up it was like fourth
grade
fourth grades too old i could see maybe
seven the teacher handed me something
and i went thanks mom and then instantly
was like oh god what am i doing i
immediately got an
uninvited from every birthday party that
year that that same year i never saw a
roller rink again huh that same year i
pissed my pants in that class
two days in a row exact same way exact
same time
run into the bathroom dude what the [__]
what are you an old lady in florida in
fourth grade you're [__] pee in your
pants
twice dude same spot the second time i
was so upset with myself wait same spot
you're like so you're just peeing on the
rug
no no i was running the [__] labrador
paying on the rug
well he said the same spot yeah it was
but they usually rub your face in it so
you don't do it again
with the newspaper a couple of times
he's a brand new carpet t-bone oh man
that teacher must have thought you were
a screw ball
no i did it on the way to the bathroom i
was running the first time and then i
like pissed
me talk about edging why wait that long
dude [__]
talk about flying too close to the sun
god damn i wanted to hear about the
pilgrims
they were getting at a good part they
just got there we were in a wild game of
seven up
heads down thumbs up seven up
nothing wrong with it yeah oh man
say did they have to break out the
[__] sawdust for you no i was just in
there
drying myself off trying to [__] hide
the evidence oh man that panic when you
do
even some drops as an adult on like a
pair of chinos or something oh i never
pee before i go on stage and people say
yeah it's to hold it and be in the
moment no because i don't want to
[__] dribble stain on my cargo pants
yeah and people would be like why is it
so high up in his waist
[Laughter]
that's my biggest fear why is it on his
shirt
because i had a huge heart on it i had
it
i had to talk to my belly band god damn
holy heck ah gang this is a family
episode we are here together the three
of us the boys
kippurino yeah that's me what's cooking
baby not much
uh i went down to uh wildwood this
weekend
real classy place i don't know if you've
ever been have you ever been
to wildwood i mean i new jersey we're
talking i've been there
i've been the aka the irish rivieras
it's known as
i spent a couple hours at maury's pier
one vacation we drove up and went over
there
not my kind of town it's a tough
lockdown didn't like it at all i was
like nah i'm going
i want to go back to ocean city yeah
yeah i'm not classy ocean city's a
classy or a classier
guy [__] dudes with pocket knives on
the boardwalk making moves on my mom and
[__]
[__] she shouldn't have been she
shouldn't have been wearing that
slime bags i didn't even this that just
this was about my head when i got there
we went to the acme i was like you know
grabbing some stuff
friday night when i got down there or
friday afternoon and this guy came in
with his son his son was like seven
the dad was clearly high clearly clearly
dude [__] ate your smoke
smoke they [__] puffing the chibis oh
that's okay it's
fine i know but he's also wearing a
shirt like
dad's best buds or something with like a
with like a pot leaf on it and i'm like
dude jesus
and he comes in down he walks into an
acme walks over to the refrigerated
section where i'm at
and they were out of pre-made turkey
sandwiches because oh no they're out of
the pre-made sandwiches
i'm like who the [__] goes all the way
down the shore to get a pre-made
sandwich
at the supermarket i'll suppose there's
like russos a
l p there's like great italian delis
down there
this guy drove to a supermarket walked
in high as [__] with a seven-year-old
kid
did any of your friends do you ever
smoke any weed with any of your friends
parents
there was a there was a house that let
us smoke weed and i still i had beers
no were they smoking yeah no they were
smoking with us down i didn't smoke at
the time but
we're all sitting down and like somebody
like one of my friends had like a new
bong so their mom was like yeah let's go
oh
smoking with adults that's real trash
and i went to the car i got a sixer i
used to like roll with beer so i went
down to the trunk and got a sixer i was
like oh we're partying
warm now it's cold i used to have a
cooler the trunk
a party car it was next to the ac unit
and the tree stump uh and they [__]
she's like you can't do that here i'm
like yo you're high as a kite right now
this wasn't medical marijuana this was
[__] 15 years ago hey lady you're
blowing a 13 year old let's not start
pointing fingers huh
if i want to [__] just try to take
the edge off and have a [__] bernie
after a long week of [__] long
division
[__] sitting here lecturing me you're
giving drugs to kids
yeah that tattoo on your left titty
tells me otherwise
i've never been like what the [__]
[__] round up the troops i'm [__]
you [__] losers find your own way
home
i try to [__] have a couple of silver
bullets and relax
i'm gonna go over the mcginty's like a
gentleman of a beer
ah you're really embracing the trash
lifestyle huh
wild wood i swear that's all i know man
is that where you would pitch a tent
things keep going the right way i got a
house would you drop a house down in
wildwood
i think it's probably the only place i
could afford i'm going straight hamptons
right on the edge of the water yeah
right houseboat maybe
working in the lighthouse
[Laughter]
and my whole family it's health
boats are crashing you forget to turn it
on out of bulbs out again
oh [__] uh but i would wild baby i got
recognized i walked into a bar
shout out to todd nice todd todd from
philly
which uh now it raises you know
we're public figures in in some
dumpsters i think all it does is hem you
up to lay a good tip on it that's what i
wanted to get
yeah this is i've been we've been
recording i've been you too like walking
down the street a couple people like yo
what's up love the pod whatever
um this was the first time we're sitting
there already ordered i think we ordered
the food tour maybe apps we're
sprinkling infield got a couple of apps
what'd you get
the fried provolone which is different i
think it's all i had
and uh we're out of food what do you got
we got some cheese back here ryan
fried provolone get the [__] out of here
it was good it was like it was like
mozzarella but
provolone mozzarella what not sticks was
it reddit
yeah yeah yeah yeah i mean it wasn't
just like you didn't hand me a [__]
tub and
melted microwave cheese in a bowl now
because you know what i learned is a
pretty nice
stacked snack for keto if you melt some
cheese in a bowl
and then take pepperonis and use them as
chips
let's try that out okay um
toby sure um had chips with his lunch
i chose chips for my lunch sure i didn't
say it was on keto
i just heard good things about this guy
i already likes the cream cheese
but so we saw now i'm going he's like
and then he's like oh
are you from are you garbage i go yeah
[Laughter]
ah she wasn't there i was boozing with
the
boozing with a pal wow real day bender
look at you
i was a little upset too i went to four
bars in a while but it finally
finally got recognized i was like i
figured you [__] bozos would have
been stopped me at the bridge
on the way over who are you jenna
maloney from [__] 30 rock trying to
get noticed
um that was a dt jesus christ that was a
toby joke right there
who are you obscure actor from that joe
from 15 years ago
um but just a sea of dms of people who
love the cuts
hey my mom has instagram too does she
no no get on that um my mom please stop
dming
mrs mcmullin's in the dms really
i all know who's got the power
holy [__] don't act like your mom's not
either
i know she doesn't have instagram i got
your mom your dad your brother
everybody's in there i know i know my
mom doesn't have instagram
but i saw you she does have an only
fancy i saw your mom was on nothing
nah i'm not giving it to you was she mad
about the [__] comment i guess it came
out today actually
we'll find out now she said that was
spot on
[Laughter]
it was in her younger days but still
but i had a tip there now i was the
first time yeah you do i had to hit him
i looked over my buddy phone i had to
tip this guy two three grand
uh but the bill was 52 bucks
big shot i know we were running around
getting drinks and some crazy provolone
huh t-bone
[__] trash bag what go down there you
already went to four bars before you got
this
that was the third jesus yeah we did a
circle
the loop did you have apps at the other
ones too no that was the first time we
got sammy's there too
yeah burgers vampirina what's today i'm
gonna join
shout out to the inlet used to be
westies
yeah like a nice barn named after a gang
that used to slice people's
throats open shout out to the iras huh
you call it's all night long welcome to
the protestant um
he hooked you up though right he gave us
a shot of fireboy because these are on
me
nice yeah real chill too it's you rarely
get chilled fireballs but anybody asking
for fireballs
man that's a bad look these days yeah
also too it was like [__] two in the
afternoon too
um hey todd how about some jmo huh come
on no well we order we ask for the
fireball
i mean like i never you know just get a
couple more of those
can you put them in a backstage please i
ended up dropping them 30 beans as a tip
nice
yeah i was plus that by that point i was
[__] torched you got to watch those
with the card because that doesn't go
right on that's a little [__]
floating
a couple days later phil phil put it on
his card i did the tip
nice cash i venmo
hey todd you a paypal kind of guy cash
app what are you working with
i just had some place that that owes me
a check i was like you want to venmo me
they're like yeah we can't do that
yeah we're a business you [__]
marmaluke all right well whatever you
gotta do i guess
well i guess i'll rescind my request
then well look at you you're getting
recognized [__] kid's a big shot
living the dream this guy
yeah doing it yeah i like it man you on
the other hand your no your no cap
t-shirt
now what does no cap stand for what do
you do i do know yeah
i think it's no caps like a surf like on
the water like the white what when the
water breaks
the white stuff wouldn't you want caps
you're a real marine biologist huh uh
the white stuff wouldn't you want if you
were surfing you would want a cap you
would want the wave to break well not if
i was chatting up some honey on my board
i wouldn't want caps
if i was ready to make a move yeah i
want okay i want tubes
also fertiliser he put the shirt on and
went who is no cat
yeah so who is no caps is it a band yeah
it is new new debut album coming out
run it up it's called 45 year old fat
guy
who's no cap you're dressed like [__]
king of queens in the later years
when he really let it go you look like a
guy getting ready for a [__] semi-pro
football tryout they both got pretty fat
on that show didn't they
she got pregnant i think i think she
they went through the pregnancy ah
i did that old thing where they just put
like a [__] pillow in front of her
every night
no that's what we're gonna do to you
he's our fault he's pregnant years guys
working into the storyline and i get
pregnant you look like you're ready to
pull a hamstring in a softball game
man so what is it [__] no cat means
like
uh no exact like it means i'm not lying
yeah not lying
[__] yeah your people are out of people
on instagram cat like captain
that's all cap if you're cap in your
line yeah like like if you post
a picture of yourself in a [__] you
know a lamborghini on tick tock or
whatever people like yo that's all cap
it's it's it's it's hood it's street
it's these young kids
that's like to use it in a sentence
fully as fat as [__]
no cat no cat no cat no cap you're fat
as [__]
uh i can't wear this then i thought it
was a surfing company or something
no it's like a straight some guy on tick
tock made that and sold him to
burlington goat factory
well you shouldn't be buying that's
another thing he just came from
burlington coat factory it's not called
bronze and coat factory anymore [__]
what's it called yeah they got lame
shirts now
it's not just coats okay the coat
factory
and shitty t-shirt company they have
five xl t-shirts that i wear
dude the collar on that thing too god
damn
you're gonna look like [__] i guarantee
you i'm feeling lightheaded this thing's
tight as [__]
the collar looks like dude it looks like
you're about to hang out a [__]
i got a bad grade like my dad's choking
me out
that thing no cat that thing stinks
what is running what does running up
mean
you're not running anywhere i know that
no cap right on my credit card bill
i don't know what run it up means dude i
mean it's a [__] t-shirt that some
[__] guy made and berlin if
burlington coat factory is selling the
t-shirts
it's not a cool t-shirt that means it
went to normal stores and
everybody said get this the [__] out of
here
marshalls wouldn't touch it no no no god
yeah they're just burlington now and
this one i didn't see coat one i'll tell
you that
it was more like a marshalls or
something because they had toys they had
frames
all the tchotchkes and all that [__]
yeah why don't you shop at po
i told you a polo order as many
exercises i was down with my parents i
have a show after this
i only you can't wear that to the show
i'm wearing this t-shirt on the show
i stopped to get a couple t-shirts
because i i only have well
yeah i had to get sneakers because i
only have my flip-flops i got a sweet
pair of adidas
no cap is that right did i use it right
yeah yeah [__] you guys you're a bozo no
cap no cap bozo over here
take your hat off because you're a no
cap bozo no no cat means
i'm not a bozo you're a bozo no cap
not exaggerating seriously i'm not what
is it what is cap
short for i don't know i'm sure we can
look it up
um not so cool now are you
lame oh no cap no lie for real often
used emphasize someone's exaggerating
to say that it's used by the younger
demographics yes
they say early 1900s yeah there you go
good look good day my lord you are no
capital no cap
[Laughter]
yeah whatever uh cool
yeah all right so i got a cool new tee
that's a deal i have a couple other ones
but they don't quite fit in the
traditional
okay yeah i saw you bought some the
stretching you have to do on your
t-shirts before you put them on
is something else kind of loosen them up
a little bit jesus christ dude you're
doing it you put them over your arms and
then do this thing
dude he steps on his t-shirts and then
does [__] curls
stretch it out it's a lot dude it is
hey whatever it is what it is okay i'm
holding the line
you just saw me weigh myself not bad i'm
down four pounds
from when you weighed me in last time i
don't know about that yes it is forget
the numbers
sure um we'll see uh the weight loss
challenge also on patreon.com
it's a [__] roller coaster guys strap
in
if you're joining now start at the
beginning of june
that thing is up and down it's like the
stock market baby i got clam chowder in
here
[Laughter]
the only thing more unpredictable than
bitcoin is foley's weight this month
these guys [__] all over the charts
i'm like kim jong-un
you don't know what i'm gonna do
kid's a hot shot you gotta give him that
real cowboy
all right gang this podcast is brought
to you by our good friends over there at
mint mobile oh yeah let's talk about it
let's do it because we're fans first
big big fan huge kippy's been using it
for years oh yeah
and here's the scoop with mint mobile
okay cut right to the chase
15 bucks a month good night so you're
thinking to yourself ah what's the rub
what's the rub
because we're used to dealing with all
these big bozos with the fine print and
this and that now
here's the scoop what is the 4-1-1 lay
it on them big man
there ain't no fine print nope what they
do
is they deal directly with you that's
why they save you
so much money fifteen dollars can't beat
it no
they sent us one uh first of all they
my wife has been using this for years
what i said fans right off the jump
because
because uh there's no contract when you
need it you re-up it's easy peasy it's
the same network it's the same speed the
same data
all unlimited i i i want to switch to it
which i might do hey so you don't have
my number anymore you know what i mean
don't be fielding calls from the big
bang
i'm going under i'm going under the
radar off the grid
yeah uh guys it's a fantastic service
check it out uh
if you're not 100 satisfied mint mobile
has you covered with their seven day
money back guarantee
it's easy peasy switch to mint mobile
get premium wireless service starting at
just
15 bucks a month uh if you're looking
for extra savings mint mobile offers
premium wireless
like i said 15 bucks a month all plans
come with unlimited talk
text high-speed data delivered on the
nation's
largest the largest right the largest 5g
network no 4g isn't it
buddy 4g three 4g probably five
g we're talking 5g that's what we're
doing the stuff that makes your hair
fall out the good stuff
yeah blow your hair back the stuff the
crazies are talking about the good
stuff yeah guys they were they're able
to cut the middleman give the savings
directly to you so to get your new
wireless plan for just 15 bucks a month
uh get the plan shipped straight to your
door go to mintmobile.com
garbage one more time write it down pull
out your phone do whatever you got to do
mintmobile.com garbage cut your wireless
build at 15 bucks
at mintmobile.com garbage now take your
head of your ass and go do it
gang let's talk about our good friends
over there at hello
fresh hello fresh i'm hungry i want
something to eat
something good something yummy what do
you do but i don't want to spend three
weeks making it what
hello fresh why what do they do what do
they do
they send food right to your door let me
tell you something first of all
we're clients yeah okay big box showed
up at my house
packed in ice fresh shrimp fresh pork
fresh chicken
i'm eating cajun shrimp over kale salad
what with crispy sweet potatoes and a
yogurt glaze
15 minutes after i opened up you
couldn't do that without the box
could not do it no way you could do that
without hello fresh
number one meal kit in the usa all right
shipped right to your door you don't got
to waste time in the grocery store
nope and here's the best thing what's
that 15 to 20 minutes they can have
meals on the table for you and your
family
whether it's breakfast on the go lunch
dinner doesn't matter
they have every single thing covered to
fit your busy lifestyle come on
yeah it's fanta i feel like a
professional chef they sent it to me i'm
[__]
they do make you feel real feels way
cool cause they take enough out of the
equation
yeah that you don't have to do it so
they make you look cool it's colored by
numbers for chefs that's what it for
cooking
yeah it's really open a tablespoon dash
it is that [__]
cause my girl was like my girl when my
girl made the uh the cajun shrimp
there's pickled onions that are in there
yeah so they give you the onions and
they give you their stuff to pickle it
like
you know that's like vinegar she's like
i made pickled onions i'm like now
hello fresh hello fresh made you pickled
onions don't be trying to pull the wool
over the big man's eyes
no i gotta get a bit darrell in the
morning to fool you
especially when it comes to anything
pickled um
the big thing when they send it to us
the the thing is me and my me and me and
a lady
will get into it in the supermarket over
this or that buying is
that's not this well that's not this you
don't know what goes in
into a recipe you think you know she
thinks you know it's yeah well this is
kind of like that my mom made it
shut it get hello fresh to send it to
you hello
fresh that's my new tag guys go to
hellofresh.com
garbage12 use promo code garbage 12 to
get 12
free meals including free shipping what
are we doing here i'll tell you what
we're doing we're saying goodbye to
hanging out in the grocery store and
being frustrated and we're saying
hello hello
fresh one more time guys get go go to
hellofresh.com
garbage12 you can use the promo code
garbage12 the link will be in the
description
you get 12 free meals including free
shipping what are we doing that's nuts
that's crazy i don't know who's doing
that over there but they should be
locked up
12 free meals that's bananas put these
guys in a straight jacket baby
now back to the show all right guys um
this one
we're doing a little different to uh
start off we got uh we got an advice
e message came in on that on that their
patreon
wow dear hank you are corny no cap
all right let's see let's pull it up
here okay names and places
are all being changed for his uh
he requested and as you know when you
join the patreon you'll get your
question
asked on air because we get too many dms
emails and all that stuff it's the best
way to streamline yes
best way to do it guys thank you toby
thank you very much um
now where the [__] can i find it this is
crazy sure look cool
yeah it looks awesome it's funny that
you said
i can't wear this at the show when i
bought it specifically two word of the
show
what i'm saying because i have
basketball shorts on and the only other
shirt i took down with me was my
short sleeve button up and you can't
wear a short sleeve button up in
in basketball shorts you're gonna wear
basketball shorts on no
you're that's what you're wearing to the
show yeah it's a summer what do you mean
you might have nice sneakers on look
cool i got my hat you've given up
what are you talking about giving up on
what what do you mean what am i talking
about you would have never
old foley would have never awarded first
of all not even cool champions those are
original issue champion shorts yeah and
where did that get me now i'm coming
into my own and i feel more like myself
than i ever do so i'm gonna express
myself do not try to defend this you
used to [__] call people
[__] and bozos wearing shorts on
stage and now because you don't have
clothes that fit
that's what you're wearing and you're
going to try to defend it that's insane
no
that's not true you're all right i want
to send lying to yourself and lying
i want to wear these wait or what my
basketball i want to wear what i'm
wearing yeah because you're not
comfortable in pants don't try to
don't try to well this summer who's
comfortable don't try to
hide it behind that you're you're
finally coming into your own
this is what your own has gotten you
your own is not a good thing
yeah it is you're wearing a no capture
you bought a burlington coat factory
it's a 5x
it don't fit and you're wearing
basketball shorts for [__] 25 years
ago
this you ain't a good you you've come
into your only option
[Laughter]
very good oh my back's against the wall
no cap
what do you got you have it in our group
text oh do i i'll send it to you right
now
man what would you do without t-bone
come on wait a minute we would be
tanking can we take a minute here
take a second what would you do without
all
t-bone probably finish the story that's
pretty good
um all right so this uh this was reached
out
uh by a guy we're gonna call a marty by
a guy named marty
marty uh marty is
throwing his first soiree
he's having a gathering a party per se
how old of a gentleman
uh he everybody's in like the 25 to 35
range
nice okay so a little you know a little
more
is it does he own this home i don't know
i don't have all of th
no he's not married okay um and he wants
to try to impress these people
okay you know to show him that he's not
a bozo okay um
he said i think i got ahead of myself by
inviting these people over i realized i
don't know what the [__] i'm doing
what advice he wanted to know what
advice we have to give him
for entertaining a group of people the
his first adult his first adult part now
we're not talking to kegger here we're
not talking like he can't throw jungle
jews
he can't throw some beers in the tub
with ice and [__] order some pizzas
and all that stuff he wants to try to
put out some chuck i don't think i don't
know if
he didn't say i don't know how classy
the guy is i mean at the end of the day
he listens to this [__] show you know
what i mean
but uh yeah well i guess if you were
entertaining
what do you have to give him all right
so i'm entertaining is
i live with my girlfriend at our place
now
no you live at wayne manor yeah you live
at your [__] apartment with your
girlfriends
things are going well i mean where else
where else would you be throwing a party
i don't know maybe this guy's house i
don't know
if they got anybody down the shore it
could be a toby's mom's house where
would you like to throw the party
i'll i'll rent a space and throw it
there no this is at your house we're in
a space all right you've never rented
you've never rented a space when i'm
entertaining i would though
now would you come i've been to your
house and you listen you don't roll out
the red carpet
okay that now take that back right now
anytime you walk into my house i offer
you something
yeah you water from the sink no i i
can't get that i can get that offer
a fresh beverage and some refreshments
say it and you decline most of it i mean
i haven't been to your house in a while
but you've only ever had
you've only ever had water that's not
true
that's very true and dirty dishes in the
in the
in the fridge yes dirty dishes in the
fridge not maybe you want this pitcher
of water that's next to the [__]
the rigatoni pan no i don't want that
okay might be a meatball in there
yeah dude all right so first thing you
want to do is you want to clean the
whole place
you've got to clean it it might even be
worth it to get somebody
to get someone in there especially when
you sign up at a place like a lot of
places you know you sign up on like
they do it in new york like the first
time is only 50 bucks or something like
that
get them in there they clean the corners
they do it nice
if you've never had your place cleaned
by a service
you got to do it treat yourself dude
it's the best 70 bucks you'll ever spend
yeah it's relatively cheap especially
the first time you can get a pretty good
deal
now i'm assuming uh marty is this is all
an inside thing now if
he if he has a back a backyard it would
be a little bit of a different approach
he is in a nicer weather place so it
could he could
there could be an outdoor space i don't
know he doesn't he didn't say clearly
doesn't have a pool though
right probably not that's a tough look
man having those parties with no pool
get the [__] out of here all right well
let's keep it to the apartment we'll
keep it to the apartment so yeah you
want to clean the place
can we we'll say apartment with deck
sure there's probably
a front porch at back porch something
marty's doing well it ain't bad to keep
the beers in a cooler out there
what what but of course let's let's take
this from the ground up
since you're wait are we renting a space
again i like how now you're involved
before you're like where am i throwing
my shindig
uh clean everything including your room
don't be one of those guys that have the
room
don't go in that room or [__] oh the
cat's in there or whatever
smells like litter or any of that [__]
um if you got a cat
send them away for the weekend if you
got a cat [__] yeah handle it
don't be putting people's coats in the
room where the cat [__] drops dumps
that's awesome because that [__] stinks
i don't think there's a coat room it's
in a warmer
uh okay i mean coat rooms are for like
stuff
my aunt's having a party for christmas
hey throw all the coats on one
on on when i was a kid you dig yeah he's
the best
yeah maybe on the other hand do a coat
room crawling through like the coat you
smell like cigarettes and perfume on the
ladies
yeah i used to find a couple of bucks in
the pocket put that right in kippy's
little purse
yeah we weren't grifting them to me
either a bunch of little houses
guys go through the jewelry boxes and
[__] [__] wet bandits over here
so i've never seen a nine-year-old with
a stopwatch i got my uncle's rolex on
highlighter bozo all right i'm going to
bed it's nine o'clock
[Music]
my bedtime i'll tuck myself in good
night everybody um
yeah make sure the place is clean clean
is is
huge so this is how you do it so you
have a definitive
um appetizer menu or hors d'oeuvre menu
and then you have dinner okay i don't
know if you're doing this is where we
might disagree you don't need to do
dinner
he's not doing dinner he's not cooking
burgers and [__] on the grill i don't
i don't know you got to stop timing me
up i don't have all of these [__]
details you're asking me like i'm
throwing a party
i don't know i feel like you're really
marty yeah
um let's say you're doing you're having
people over you're asking me how to do
it i'm telling you how to do it yeah
well you're going does he have a girl i
don't have that's i've given you all the
information i have so stop asking me for
details okay fine then i'm gonna take it
from there there you go so what you want
to do is
you want to make sure there's an
assortment of beverages yes out on the
deck
if there's a people who can serve
themselves yes unless he has the money
you hire a bartender and set a little
borrower
he's not doing that okay cool so you
have all that stuff out if you do have
an outdoor you do an outdoor that way it
creates multiple areas so i'm going to
pop outside grab a beer
outside grab a beer you set up a little
bar area with ice if people want to make
a mixed drink
make sure you put the sodas and the
capri suns in a separate cooler or
whatever
from the alcoholic beverages because
that's how you get kids
on the path to [__] alcohol and drug
edition addiction
by putting the capri suns where the
[__] coors lights were yeah
also non-alcohol beverages a pro move in
case somebody has to drive or sure
have some seltzer some tonics you know
whatever onyx
this guy who's drinking who's drinking
tonic i don't know what pussy's not
drinking that's what if you are you're
not coming to my party t-bone tell you
that much
okay that's how you know your family's
real booze bags when the only
non-alcoholic option is tonic
saying have some some orange juice for
the screwdriver can i get you a glass of
sour mix
it's only 17 what
[Applause]
dude also pro move you get the cooler
with the nice beers
in the fridge on the shelves nice beers
and then in your crispers the drawers on
the bottom
throw some [__] bud lights some
people no
no for once no no listen listen for once
the nice beers run out
and then and then a couple people have
left and now you're into the night and
everybody's getting too
no he's right he's right what you doing
no he's not you're not stocking you're
not taking your
vegetables out of your in your
refrigerator a listener to this show
doesn't have vegetables yeah what are
you talking about
listen this no this put anything in your
crispy stop it this is a pro move
stop it no it's not first of all you
only go to parties at your parents you
go to your mom's house you literally
only go to parties
can i get a beer yeah there's one in the
butter drawer in the [__]
refrigerator no
you get a bunch of cheap beer because if
especially if there's no kids when that
goes off like the party goes on people
start playing drinking games
whether it be beer pong or flip cup or
kings or whatever that's what they start
doing
and you use the cheap beer for that yeah
or or you're all full up on ipas you
don't want to [__] be sucking down a
car sure you need that is a pro move to
have cheap beer
not on the house in the crisper though
relax yeah and the crisp dude you've
never been when was the last party
you've gone to first of all that hasn't
been at a family member's house
your mom or your brothers what's the
difference it's still a party no that's
the only way you only know
the way you do things you never gonna
experience how other people do that's
not an adult
party that's a pirate my whole life i'd
never wanted anybody's crisper to get it
if it's a drink
if it's in like a girl yes dude if
somebody only has a garage or whatever
or then i separate you didn't say it was
thank you appetizers what are we doing
we like to get a tray of nuggets
from chick-fil-a we do a chick-fil-a
chicken that's not bad it also depends
on the vibe of the crew if the crew is
like a little trashier you can get
that's
you know okay if it calls for a little
higher end maybe you do the charcuterie
board
sure uh you can even what what is a
pretty pro move is order if there's like
a place around that has like good wings
or whatever
order that put it in your own [__]
your own dishes right like your own
person like if you do have a tray
sure order the whatever if there is
something where you're like oh everybody
loves the [__] wings at mahoney
or whatever yo i got 50 mahoney's wings
on the way
yup bada bing bada boom yabba-dabba-doo
all right i'm with that
you got to go heavy on the apps i think
if you go heavy on the apps and you tell
everybody you're not having dinner
like you're not if you don't have a
grill or whatever i don't know what kind
of house this guy lives in
i'm thinking he is a grill i have a lot
of faith in this kid that's fine i've
got a grown a deck
i'm also just saying if he doesn't
you're not obligated to serve dinner at
a
at a party at like a cocktail party as
long as there's enough
people know that too going into it
because if you're gonna
if you're getting invited over you're
getting invited for like a dinner party
where you're like oh we're serving
it's a barbecue is different than a hang
you know what sets that tone
is it a mass text going out yo come by
my house around five
or are we talking evite no it was uh it
was a personal invitation
hey my place all right next
your mother's [__] whatever it is
okay um
and then i'm sure there's been some
follow-up uh uh calls and texts and
confirmations
do your chips in the pretzels do your
chips your pretzels guac is always big
hummus some pita chips big can i can i
throw something out there
chips and pretzels go in like a big
plastic thing but make sure you put down
a paper towel or something
put down a paper towel inside the bowl
that's the trash that's like 90s trash
don't do that you can do something other
than paper towels and
dumping a [__] bag of lays out also
don't do that that's skating party
[__] can we just talk about the the
trash that is the eight layer bean dip
not a fan i hit the bricks thanks
take that [__] [__] back to wherever
you buffalo chicken dip on the other
hand good night good
[__] night if you if one of the girls
or whoever can whip up a mean [__]
buffy chick dip
have them do that bring it over buffalo
chicken dip and shrimp cocktail are
[__]
if you have a crock pot buffalo chicken
dip in the crock pot
real easy yeah not a bad idea man when
you when you when you're going down that
line on the [__] table
and you [__] you see that crock pot
sitting there
always take a peek inside that thing so
at our place it's always [__]
uh sausage and peppers and meatballs
sausage peppers
meatballs in the oven and my favorite
sausages and peppers they're my favorite
um ain't nothing wrong but you don't
have to do a proper meal
right also like i don't know you guys
could be kind of you know more on the
dirt ball side and you could be like hey
i got 15 pizzas from
antonio's coming over there you go which
ain't two shot which is like no
everybody's down for like a pizza and
beer night if that's the way you kind of
you spin it not too sh everybody knows
they're kind of slumming it yeah well
you have to do one thing that's kind of
like
the centerpiece of the party
you know what i mean so if you're gonna
do the pizzas and stuff like that
this is the way this is the way you run
a pizza at a party
you don't order you don't say they're
coming you don't order them as the party
goes on a few hours
in you go you guys hungry should i get
some pizzas
don't accept any money from anybody boom
the guy from skinelli's is at the door
i got a better i've seen it done better
by casey b
former guest on her uh
not halloween party super bowl parties
casey of the legendary super bowl party
the legend that she gets
[__] a stack of pizzas doesn't tell
you saka peaches just show up at
halftime
and you're like what the [__] new party
fresh blood
you know what i mean you're [__]
hanging out at that point you're already
about [__] you got a sixer in here or
whatever
next thing you know they dropped 15 zaws
at the bar the slices start flying good
night
that's a pro move just don't tell them
like if you are gonna do that have like
two or three pizzas come in
and just let it show up that's the class
move oh yeah we got pizzas from
antonio's for later
or now open one up leave it on the stove
or whatever
put the other away ah for later for you
know how do you feel about the can i
bring anything
i said well i'm asking this also i just
had a plan
and do my my wife's whole birthday
last weekend or two weekends ago when i
had this idea what that you're gonna do
your wife's birthday no i
we had we planned like that the park
hang so it was like 15 people come in
and we had to get everything like
i entertained what was this we've talked
about this
have we yes multiple times i didn't get
invited to that either
we just did a whole episode of hard
feelings about that it was like a
[__] it was like
14 minutes of the episode one you forgot
it was her birthday when we had to
change the recording schedule
to accommodate her birthday oh yeah i
told you it was her birthday
you then go what the [__] it was her
birthday i should have texted her i go
you had the chance toby did well you
didn't go to her party did you
we've had this conversation did we oh my
god
[__] scumbag hey you invited the dry
cleaner you are losing your mind
you didn't go though are you insane
i don't remember that's [__] up though
so what'd you do that's what i'm saying
you have to when people say hey can we
bring anything
as long as you have you know somebody
shows up with the vegan [__]
you have to have a lot of your bases
covered you can't rely on everybody
no if you want smarty don't do that yeah
marty don't have one guy bring the chips
another guy bringing his hat
you gotta have her fighting over the
last lemon square yeah
you're gonna wind up with 12 bags of
original lays yeah yeah
dude yeah i've done that dude i've done
that for kcb's
halloween or a super bowl party she'll
be like hey can you grab chips and it's
been me and like three other bozo
comedians meet each other at the bodega
by accident
and we're all standing in line holding
like tostitos or whatever and i'm like
oh we look like i'm like we all can't
roll in with the same baggage absolute
jerk we look like [__] [__]
oh also solo cups hundred of them come
on
hundred solo make sure you got plenty of
solo cups ice [__] plenty of ice you
need
to get an extra big bag and put it in
the [__]
freezer get rid of the eggo waffles
whatever you got in there
a party that runs out of the ice right
[__] get out of here
you're drinking like a warm rum and
coconut way through the water
or you know what's the trashiest is
using the ice from like
where they have the beers and stuff
stored i don't mind that everybody
sticking their hands in there that ain't
ideal but what are we doing
that's what it is that's what it is
stunned you know how you know how you
solve that problem you toss a solo cup
and leave it in there
yeah yeah a lot of people scoop i'll fi
well it's not ideal
right but my germaphobe my germaphobia
gets checked when booze is involved
if it means kippy gets another [__]
martini i'm having some [__] dirty
ice in there yeah but you need the solo
cups or when people want to start doing
shots so you're not having a guy with a
mug
wwe commemorative cup he's got like the
butter container [__]
yeah you saw get a hundred solo cups
that way people trap whatever and don't
be the guy like write your name on your
you gotta let people you gotta have
enough to let people be free don't you
can't be having too many rules
the big question also you should keep
the shoes on come on if you don't be
totally because you're going in and out
of the deck
and hang trash bags in different areas
oh that's pretty and make sure you have
a designated bernie spot so people can
pull their darts
yeah and not feel like a dirt bike yeah
hey oh sig's out front there's a lighter
there's a whatever
there's a can out there like a coffee
can you can put them in air yeah i buy
buy a couple of lighters have them out
there people start drinking they don't
always smoke like a lot of my family
parties none of them
not everybody smokes but when they start
but they start boozing kippy's around
with the bernies
everybody yeah i'll have one of those
they'll bring they'll buy packs and then
give them to me hey
break these out in a couple you know
break these out around around 8 p.m
but you got to have the lighters have
you got to set it up do it nice and then
music
music's a big thing what are you getting
a band
it depends is the face big enough marty
hire weezer
uh now you just do a [__] gotta have
a good playlist
yeah lex or whatever you're into it
can't be
you know whatever you guys are it
depends i don't know these could be
[__] punk rock kids
what about bows what do you think about
bows my dad's in the market for a new
bose
he's like i want to get a bose a bose
boat i want to listen to the radio
so you have an alexa you have all that
[__] it's already there you don't need
the bows anymore
yeah i think bose is trashy just write
bows on alexa
i won't know um
yeah and if you don't have good taste in
music something like pandora or spot go
on spotify
look look up literally look up like
party playlists yeah hipster barbecue or
whatever you can do like rock and roll
barbecue like all that [__] and like
they they have it pretty curated
so but you gotta have a speaker like and
if you don't have a speaker don't buy
one or have someone hey bring
your bows or whatever if you don't know
and a contingency plan in case it rains
oh move everybody inside yeah and if you
don't have a speaker it's garbage but
it's good in the pinch just run it off
the tv
that's not too shabby either yeah not
too bad
you got a smart tv you can yeah whatever
if you're like
that's also another thing people
watching no tv at the party
oh so what's there's a game on game on
different story sure game
on yeah game on sound yeah off
music playing but the music playing i
don't hate that but like you just
you got money on it do you ever see some
people like sitting down at like
watching tv at someone else's house i'm
like what are you doing you [__] bozo
[__] people hanging there's chicks
here [__] watching
friends reruns what are you doing i
remember one year we had thanksgiving at
my cousins
and she brought her my cousin one of
their daughters brought a friend
oh that's always bad it was yeah and she
went up and took a nap
for like a while what yeah a nap
how old was she they're like in college
no yes
she's sleeping over [__] oxycontin or
something
nobody just takes a nap at a party dude
that's
crazy no way unless you're trying to get
your baby get your bearings straight
are you getting your what you're bearing
straight yeah
hey listen i gotta sleep dissolve still
a little [__] shook up from the
corner
nah if somebody comes over my house and
tries to take a nap i'm kicking them the
[__] out and for the love of god no naps
no [__] board games dude no no board
games
what about heads up that's fun what's
heads up with the phone heads up
that's all right depends on if it's just
also this could be a slower crowd you
know what i mean poker
poker play strip poker no we said we had
this conversation with akash
talking about spin the bottles spitting
the bottle seven that's all that was all
he's not playing that at the party
maybe he is i don't know
um what about the desert
what are you putting out you got to do i
would get something
i got two words local if there's like a
cookie company or whatever
stop mini cupcakes crowd pleaser
just a bite get him at the grocery store
mini
cupcakes that's the way you want to go
it's nice brownies insomnia cookies like
cookies
yeah like sure something like that if
there's like a place where you're at
that's like oh
johnny's has the best [__] whatevers
you know hey i got a [__] i got two
dozen of johnny cakes coming over
balloons
balloons no no balloons no no
decorations
no decorations no decorations t-bone no
you're either 70 or you're nine
and i can't tell no cat daddy oh he's a
no-cap kid
how about water balloons at my mommy
what time's your water fight guys
get those pants off hey when's this
[__] clown getting here
there you go have a nice have a nice
party chicken nuggies
[__] chips and salsa [__] cheese
board
and go over buy more beer than you'll
ever think you'll need
that's the [__] worst even if you
don't have room to ice at all or put it
in your fridge whatever your whatever
you're working with
[__] have it on the side and then one
like it's getting low dump more in or
whatever that's your [__] job you
gotta be johnny on the [__] spot with
the beer johnny in this nothing's worse
than when they're like
hey t-bone can you grab me a beer and
t-bone goes in he's like there's one
corona left there with that and you're
like
i'll take a [__] schmidty's and
t-bone's right do two things
you want two designated areas for
recyclables and trash
but you gotta go around and keep that
[__] place clean
cause there's nothing worse than a
shitload of water bottles that's also a
classy move too
the water bottle have a cooler just
designate it
you need about four coolers that's
that's 1314 unless you want to use the
without the crisper you have your nice
beers crisper is completely fine
you have your nice i get beers out of
people's crispers garage fridge
garage fridge yes regular fridge is no
good okay but what if you don't have
that and that's your only
option this guy might be in an apartment
you have to relax and say okay he might
have to put him go to [__]
target and get a cooler okay get the
foam ones the phone ones are
oh that's [__] tread no way i'd
rather get him out of his [__]
bathtub than a foam
if do not marty listen to me
do not get a foam phone those foam ones
always have bait in them
they come with a set of night crawlers
in there those things
stink i hated those ever since i was a
kid
oh dude i can hear that squishing around
on the lid and the [__]
no way dude i'm like you can't put
anything you can't put a case of beer in
there they start
cracking and then the lids cracked and
the sides crack the [__]
no no there's nothing worse than [__]
those things
yeah and grab like a sampler like a
24-pack sampler is a nice move
that's not too shabby too like a line in
cougar where you get ipa
summer summerfest something
same edges also have someone party back
have someone have a have have the if you
guys are into it the white claws ladies
love the white calls guys
like birds love them white clothes
because there's no sugar no carbs
everybody loves white people or the high
noons the high noon shout out to the bar
still squad
big on the high noons yeah yeah yeah do
them classy
anything like that those things are i
was had i got a couple [__] white
clothes on the beach yesterday
let me tell you though something fun
even if there's no kids if you get a
couple of capri suns or some juice boxes
in there
it's fun it's sketchy people like it
yeah not at my parties no it's kitschy
what do you i think you just want
capri suns i've never been like oh guys
he's got caprice
isis is so kitschy where the bernie's at
and give me the [__] nosebeard
i'm not gonna say a rip roaring rush
wouldn't [__] do me right right now
oh [__] load of toilet paper pretty good
yeah
that's i assume that's a must can't be
wrong dude you're running out of
first of all who's who's dropping a
who's taking a digger
no for the ladies come on dude taking
the [__] at the party is so
tragic dude i remember the bar one time
i was like i'm waiting for the stall
because i was like hemmed i was like i
might i
where i'm like i ha i don't know i might
be able to hold it
if not i'm gonna have to figure some
stuff out poop i had a poop and a
ball i like
[Laughter]
like red sky or denim or something and
i'm in there
never take a [__] at a place you had to
be covered again it was there was a
bathroom attendant and stuff but i was
just like heading up and i'm like
i'm like i'm waiting for i'm waiting for
the thing you're killing some poor guy's
vibe trying to do bump skis in the next
stop and the guy's like
uh well i was like i gotta see what it's
like i'm def i have to see what it looks
i mean
who's saying this to you i'm saying this
the guy's like you can go
i think i was up next for the urinal and
i was like about to i had like [__] i
was about to have diarrhea and i'm like
there's no way i can find a public
bathroom in this school like
i have to see what the stall looks like
in this place
because sometimes those bars just all
pee you know it's just they take this
they take the lids off yeah
you can't poop it's just dude's [__]
pissing all over so i'm like i gotta put
eyes on this thing
so i get in there and it was bad and i'm
like i can't do this
i [__] ran out and pooped in a jazz
club or something
that jazz club on sampson street you
know where it is it's like
it's at like 15th and samson africa oh i
know you're talking about philly i was
thinking the west village for some
reason
you taking a deuce at the blue note
[Laughter]
oh man oh god that's funny um
lock up your prescriptions have you
expected a foley
oh there's never been a bathroom i
haven't been in where i haven't just
peaked a little bit the medicine cabinet
yeah also make sure your bathroom's
clean too you don't want like the shower
curtains closed i don't want to be
looking at your [__]
you know no dog looking at your pubes if
you have some psycho dog lose them but
if you've got a friendly dog
of course yeah yeah sparklers depends we
gotta make sure everybody's okay with
the dog too
get some works some work some works
fireworks
[__] yeah come on summertime set a
couple off
i don't know a couple of spinners the
the fireworks that sounds more like the
capri sun group but if you ask me
yeah i'm a big firework guy and that's a
and that's usually a we'll like
go down the alley away because it can
bum people out
yeah don't don't do fireworks unless you
like live on a farm especially the way
we do them
if you live in a townhouse community
don't do [__] fireworks
bosses there you're a hillbilly dude
what do you know
and for the record if you're doing
mortars don't put them in a tube set
them off on the ground like a real fun
guy oh my god
put some memories to my mateys
ah sounds like a nice part anything else
you can tell me no that's it that's all
i know
he just want you know what are some do's
and don'ts he doesn't he's like i don't
want to look like a [__] bozo here
keep it clean man keep it clean don't
run out of anything
keep it simple too don't no you don't
need you can go right up the [__]
middle
cold beer give you [__] some food to
eat that's all anybody needs [__] yeah
something that's
it some beers some oh make sure you get
wine wine for the broil yeah get a
couple bottles of wine you could even be
a box they even like that
also the birds like that oh i love box
wine it's okay yeah also
[__] what's bad well send a text of
what jesus christ i have a [__] i
didn't hear that
that caught up to me a couple seconds
later holy heck there big man
i'm kidding no no no that was specific
that was about a real person yeah uh
yeah
wowza big man just unraveled she never
loved me
she walked out on me i hate that [__]
no cap
no i'm saying that though i was joking
obviously but women
or people do take pride not women but
people take pride in
oh i don't mind box wine box wine's not
a bad thing well this is what you do
that's awesome
move on we got a couple more questions
but we love this style [__]
yeah this is this this lane of
questioning is fire
it's a great question yeah um but you
also
also there's nothing wrong with sending
out a text that day the day before yo
what are you drinking what are you you
know getting better nobody go in my room
what are you drinking tonight
you know just to get it to get a feel of
like if nobody's drinking wine also
you probably know that you know these
people somewhat so gang so far this
so hang on so gang so far this is what i
got i got some pizzas i got this does
anybody want anything they want anything
specific anything i'm missing
but anything i forgot yeah whatever feel
free to bring whatever you want if you
want otherwise
whatever that's awesome we never do that
the foliage
yeah that's a lot i wouldn't do that i
don't like the asking what you like
i just cover all the bases because
that's so much classier than having like
been that that to me but i mean that
goes with that no i'm operating on a
submission you're covering the bases but
it's also someone's like yo i really
love
you know whatever i was you know you can
take care of that
so they have it like i'm not saying like
if somebody i want yingling
i want miller light just to buy those
too i'm saying cover your [__] bases
but at the same time like find out oh
yeah i'm not drinking
why like you know because you also don't
want to run out if everybody's drinking
[__] wine or white clothes
and you only bought [__] seven then
you're [__] then nobody then everybody
has to drink what they don't really want
to drink
so i don't think there's a problem with
taking a yo i got this this this and
this
what do you know what are you drinking
let me tell you this what are you
planning on now if you know your people
like you said like you know i don't know
how well you know i think they're newer
friends my cousin like my i know what my
dad drinks so my brother drinks i know
my cousin's drinking that's different so
we know to have yingling we know to have
plenty of miller lights they love that
milly lights down here i've been on
cores all summer long love them they
love
them my one boy's now on heineken zeros
yeah i don't keep a couple of sixers of
them but let me tell you there's nothing
worse than walking to a party
and finding a [__] cooler of just
land sharks
or some [__] shitty babies that's
what i'm saying yeah it's like you can't
go you gotta
you gotta cover your bases and then
[__] find out if someone
i think it's a nice touch of like oh
yeah i [__] you got a six-pack or
whatever for me that's a [__]
to me that's a class that's a class move
hmm
let us know how it went marty yeah marty
a couple of picks would love to know
especially late night yeah if you have
any like
party moves that you develop over the
years [__] let us know too yeah it's
pretty [__] yeah
i can steal them pawn them off as my own
but i will say this i wouldn't be
throwing a party just to put a cap in
this
because you don't have any friends yeah
who would the [__] go to your
just who would go to your who would you
invite you guys
i'm busy i haven't told you what night
it was oh yeah
i would definitely have the grill going
sure there'd be something being smoked
for 12 hours
there would be a centerpiece of food
then there's burgers and hot dogs and
ribs and [__] like that yeah
it's a barbecue do you have a smoker
yeah it's his mom
and my parents get on it if we
as well also but you yeah no in my
apartment no i don't know
well i'm saying now you're at the you
can't say we
when you live that far from your parents
and you're 45 years old
you can't also tag along as hey we're
entertaining
i'm the one working the grill [__]
and stocking the beers in the coolers in
the fridge
so i can say that yeah most 45 year olds
do that at their own house
they don't go home to the [__] mommy
and daddy buy all the food and a beer
for the week
hey well you loaded the fridge for us i
like my parents
yeah we did this we just did this on
saturday
at a lovely time yeah i saw a picture
yeah pool was hot
ready to go all right go ahead
um all right this is from maddie hello
from norway love the show
norway baby on the europe international
we've gotten some people asking us when
the international
tours are coming would you go what the
[__] yeah okay while playing it
well i'll see the summer develops okay
see how let's see how joe b and putin
get along this week um all right this
one's from
start making international plans hello
from norway love the show this is a home
run of a question is it gar
is it trash to bring a laptop with you
when you're in the bathroom pooping
yeah yeah that's a tough look your phone
is
your phone your phone is fine yeah you
overlook your phone
you overlook that yeah that's
everybody's doing that
how hard are you working yeah how long
are you in there or how hard are you
jerking i think
i don't get that to me because the
computer's more of like a communal thing
your phone is yours
your computer's on the kitchen table
like you're like people are using it i
don't even think they think you're in
there pooping you get poop there's part
there's definitely poop particles on it
we've learned about them this year those
poop articles they're everywhere so it's
like you're doing that and then i i
get it's on your phone your phone's a
real dirt i don't know it's a hard dough
for me how about an item if i walked
into my service area on an ipad
yeah it's all touch screens and stuff
too nah
nah no there should what do you i don't
get it i don't get it i could turn it
into a pink ipad
[Laughter]
i think there's a thing if like i walked
into my buddy's house and he was walking
out of the bathroom with a computer
under his arm i'd be like i'm [__]
leaving
we're not hanging out yeah that's too
weird
that's too weird yeah no um
this is [__] all right this one's
from tj uh i think it's
uh i'm assuming
put yourself in the suburbs if you can
do that right uh
has anyone in your family ever called a
taxi to their house
like if you do if you're in the suburbs
call them a taxi
and there's like a if there's ever been
a yellow taxi out front of your house or
in your driveway you've been hemmed up
that is the definition of hemmed up in
the suburbs but it's never yellow it's
definitely black oh yeah it's always
like the weird color
oh white and red or something like that
soft dude i don't even get in cabs that
aren't yellow
no no the green ones i do sometimes
yeah oh yeah i'm sorry the green ones of
course yeah take those all the time
yeah but those ones in philly it's like
where'd you get these from another city
yeah they're red and yellow and did you
guys get these from a bunch of cities
that closed
did you get these from detroit what's
going on here dude get the [__] out of
here yeah that's a tough tough look
i mean if you're going to the airport or
something like that if you're going on a
trip
now there's no reason uber it's uber
yeah i mean i was gonna say
get a car i mean that's a tough look i
know my pa
we've flown a couple places whoa hey big
smash as a family
and we didn't take no [__] so get my
aunt drop you off at the airport you
have family that drops you up at the
airport picks up
taking a [__] taxi you're running
something something you're running what
is happening yeah something not good is
that if i saw if i saw a taxi in my
neighborhood that's what i'm saying if
you
dude if you looked out the window and
there was one in the neighbor's driveway
so you guys there's a body or something
something's happening there's a crime
for sure there's a crime hey mom don't
talk to the things anymore
yeah don't wait this one uh all right
this is for william
uh have you ever taken home hospital
clothes aka socks scrubs shorts gowns
etcetera
[__] yeah i stole the grippy socks yeah
there's a banjo grim
there's been some socks in my house for
sure they got the no grip on the bottom
dude i'd be walking up the wall it's a
spiderman
are yeah
and i'm paying for him right that's the
garbage way to look at
i am though he's taking the [__]
throwing the matter giving him to you
taking the bedpans and [__] with you
this is my box of tissues
this is my remote control take a nurse's
computer home with me
um jesus christ
all right uh let's see this is this is
class this is i think i don't know this
is from john k
y uh did you ever have those plastic
cereal bowls with the straw built into
them so you could drink the milk
what you've never seen those no oh these
were 90s things i think
uh let me pull it up oh no it's
in i don't i've never [__] with them
t-bone did you have them no
that that sounds to me like some 90s
[__] like the the pants that change
color due to heat
that sounds like 90s [__] kid [__]
that's what it sounds like
this [__] turn you turn the ball man
you turn the ball
get the [__] out of here i have seen
them send me that
yeah yeah dude vote most likely to get
beat up in college those things stink
i don't think you're using it in college
you're not like [__] sitting in the
cafeteria you're not bringing that
i'm saying if you were that kid that's
not a good that's no you [__] turn
the ball like a gentleman
what about the spoons that change colors
i don't know what that is yeah what are
you talking about
you don't remember that they had they
always have the commercial for it it was
like a prize
in some cereals where it would be like
red and then you dip it in the
milk and the the cold makes it change
colors well that's not bad
any pride any any legitimate
three-dimensional object that surprised
in a cereal box is they okay with me
as long as it's not a sticker or a
sticker or a puzzle or something stupid
no cap'n crunch used to give you little
submarines that you put baking soda in
in the tub
they were great they dive down [__]
legit or those octopuses
that used to crawl on the walls do you
remember those yeah yeah oh
those things are great little soap and
water that's like they're brand new
i used to love those things i don't have
no idea what the [__] really [__] with
anything my toys were way closer yeah no
[__] you ate breakfast at a diner when
you were a kid
who did you're telling me you never went
to a diner every once in a while yeah me
too
suburban diners got out the street in
bustleton still there all baking done on
premises
maybe he's eight years old with black
coffee and a marble light
black coffee egg white omelets and and
tomato slices
instead of [__] hash browns not gonna
iced
damn i was gonna ask you what do you
think of egg beaters are they trashy
i would that doesn't cross our radar but
yeah
if it's coming in a [__] carton hit
the [__] bricks okay
toby a couple of great a's or nothing
okay how do you feel about egg beaters
kick
rocks yeah i don't even know what they
were my [__] one friend's dad
i'm never gonna know what they are
either okay i'm never gonna learn what
the [__] they are i'll do an egg white
egg whites all right
but i'm not doing an egg beat no getting
an egg white omelette
yeah of course hold on yeah that's the
classier version
but i remember his mom trying to [__]
put push those on us you want some egg
beaters get the [__] out of here yeah
i'd call my dad
he's trying to pick me up let's go leave
work early
i better smell some french toast cooking
in a minute
that cinnamon better hit my nose soon
yeah [__] that [__] dumb bro
some friends parents just didn't know
what was going on take that take those
eggs be
egg beaters in your multi-grain bread
yeah and go back to the [__] store
it's like you want to get the receipt
for that you want to stay over dinner
lady i'd rather take my chances in the
street
no [__] way either call up dominoes
or call my dad i ain't eating your weird
meatloaf okay see you later [__]
lentil loaf
[__] that okay and get me a [__] diet
coke lose this milk business
dude if you've got egg beaters in your
fridge you're definitely eating eggplant
parmesan for dinner dude
yeah people i mean if you're having
company you got to get it together
um all right this one's from mike s uh
ever had a sunoco bumper sticker on your
car
because it used to be like you got like
three percent offer so there was
something you could win free gas for a
week
or something my parent my mom was your
parents you just went
real you just went real hillbilly did
you know that
what you don't you don't know what's
going on i don't think you know what's
been happening in the past 35 minutes
i was gonna say my mom's not loyal like
that she goes to the lowest bidder
every [__] day it don't matter where
you are or who you are yeah she'll cut
you out of the [__] operation she
treats guests like she's
like looking for a roofer oh lois bitter
yeah she'll drive the [__]
hickoryville of the [__]
load up she goes everywhere right now
she's wawa all the way because wawa's
got the good number on the gas
yeah good price they're moving units
they're moving units got to deal with
opec or something i don't know
talking to the saudis but either way
it's coming up paddy
um all right let's do one more never a
punch card never
anything like that i got my punch guard
i might i still i told you i
got the haircut i still have it they
keep giving it to me
jesus they know me there shout out to
gotham city you only have like how many
haircuts you think
i think about that every time i think
i'm like is this the one before i sit
down and go i look i take one look at me
go this might be it this might be the
one you have less than
how many haircuts you think he has left
in him be honest
how often are you getting a haircut once
a month minimum once a month
yeah she got like three left
so do you unfortunately get a dead man
walking here huh
this guy's walking the mile uh you have
30 haircuts left yeah i was going to put
it in the 23 years
yeah that's probably about right i'll be
close to 40. that makes sense
cool yeah fine with it you have about 20
until you croak
die in the chair
[Laughter]
all right
all right let's do this one and then
take it easy this is from drew ever own
a striptease pen where the lady's
clothes saw slide off when you turn it
upside down
man those were the cool kids you showed
up to class with that and it's like
snuck it
oh i thought i could get a stinger just
thinking about it
start pitching a tent just thinking
about those days some redheads with a
couple of privates
yeah yeah it's great that and you know
what else is
in that the beauty playing cards that
but even they have them in uh
like at the bar the the erotic photo
hunt at like the bars
oh oh i was big a big erotic photo dude
those things that are on you're talking
about things that are on the bar
yeah they're like they look like old tvs
yeah they spin a little bit oh
big fan of them big dude you got it
that's
a shitty place yeah oh yeah me and my
buddies
me and my buddies would play photo hunt
heavy was it all dirty photo huh cause i
remember there'd only be a couple mixed
in there sometimes
we would do the all-male review see what
a real one looks like
would they show wieners i think so quick
but they showed the titties in a muff i
just say muff who am i
all right we gotta go [__] it's fully
southern out of nowhere
yeah you're from 1912. yeah i'm a sailor
for joe piscopo
everybody and his broad got a muff on it
ah that's it that's it we gotta rap gang
listen we look
jesus gang listen we love you guys very
much thank you for everything kippy what
are you gonna tell them
that's it guys uh first of all check me
out on social media at cameron comedy on
all social media get those instagram
numbers
up closing in on 10k about uh live shows
you know uh subscribe on youtube leave a
review
on uh itunes the whole nine yards and uh
tickets to the live shows that's it
we love you we'll see you next week
peace